Bharati Bora from the Washington Wizards
were blazing a trail for his country two
and a half minutes to go Nuggets down by
10 through the legs apart
y'all knocks it in cherry pick oh jeez
chirping oh gee
[Applause]
Wow
so Trey Young has now dribbled the
chatted away at Atlanta on the run here
comes Dre young guy trying to clown see
Trevor about having it
dribble between the wickets of a
reasonable
as a throw right between his legs which
he's done to a lot of people to see a
trick Trevor not playing it
Trevor will take the foul and the tech
and whatever else before he's gonna let
you do that then he go through the legs
here the Nutmeg he sure did
he's done that a lot this season
straight he threw that between Rubio's
leg
nutmeg in five quick points beat brutal
ball to Ricky will be Olynyk now you
know Ricky's gonna catch it from his
team now watch this boob around digit
right through the wicket team's gonna
get nice opportunities against you
pray about Spelman big-time crash and
kuzmin's hurt Spelman will go to the
line nice pass another nice pass